which MCU character is the biggest a
superhero the size of an ant versus one
the size of an entire planet the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has featured both
tiny and huge characters and I'm here to
show you just how much of a difference
there is between these characters
comparing the sizes of some of our
favorites such as Ant-Man and the
Incredible Hulk most of all though I'll
show you which character is the biggest
out of all of them we know about and
here's a hint it's not certer or erisham
the judge
keep in mind with these size comparisons
is that most of the measurements are
estimates from the television series and
movies so there might be some slight
discrepancies between this list and what
we see in future Marvel projects anyways
let's get into it starting off with the
two smallest main characters in the MCU
we have Ant-Man and the WASP these
characters and anyone who's able to use
pin particles to shrink smaller than the
size of an atom are so small that they
enter a place called The quantum realm
featured in the upcoming film Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania these subatomic
characters are the smallest out of any
we've seen in the MCU up next is Anthony
and all the rest of Scotland's insect
friends that he makes in the Ant-Man
films while these aren't necessarily
main characters I still thought it would
be nice to include these ants coming in
at around half an inch or 1.27
centimeters tall next up is throg the
thor-like frog-sized hero who made a
small cameo in the Disney plus series
Loki this character comes in at about 4
inches or 10.2 centimeters tall our next
tallest Marvel character is Baby Groot
coming in at 1 foot 3 3 inches or 38.1
centimeters tall this lovable little
tree can grow Vines and make himself
smaller or larger as needed but as a
toddler this is the size he's usually at
up next is Howard the Duck the
well-dressed talking duck who's made
several Cameo appearances in the MCU and
he measures in at two foot seven inches
or 78.7 centimeters tall next is
alligator Loki with a height of 3 feet
or 91.4 centimeters and he too was
featured in an episode of the Loki
series on Disney plus the next largest
character is Rocket Raccoon the
quick-witted destructive cybernetically
enhanced raccoon from the Guardians of
the Galaxy and he measures in at three
foot two inches or 96.5 centimeters tall
up next we have Ms Marvel the Scarlet
Witch and Captain Marvel otherwise known
as Kamala Khan Wanda maximoff and Carol
Danvers respectively all measuring in at
5 foot 5 inches or 1.65 meters tall our
next tallest character is Natasha
Romanoff or Black Widow the KGB assassin
turns expert Shield spy and she measures
in at five foot seven inches or 1.7
meters tall not much taller than Black
Widow is Hawkeye or Clint Barton the
highly skilled bow and arrow Marksman
and member of The Avengers his height
comes in at just five foot eight inches
or 1.73 meters tall
up next is our friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man coming in at five foot nine
inches or 1.7 meters tall although he's
under six feet tall he can still pack
quite a punch
the next tallest MCU characters are
Shang Chi the 10 Ring super powered
martial artist and Wong Master of the
mystical arts and current sorcerer
Supreme both measuring in at 5 foot 10
inches or 1.78 meters tall
next up is Bucky Barnes or the Winter
Soldier measuring up at 5 foot 11 inches
or 1.8 meters tall Bucky has seen some
tremendous growth throughout the
different phases of the MCU and I mean
that figuratively not literally our next
tallest characters are t'challa and Tony
Stark or the Black Panther and Iron Man
and their heights are six foot or 1.83
meters tall up next is Dr Steven strange
Master of the mystical arts and former
sorcerer Supreme as well as Peter Quill
or legendary space Outlaw Star-Lord both
characters measure up to six foot one
inches or 1.85 meters tall next up are
Icarus and Steve Rogers or Captain
America although these two characters
cannot be more different they do have
the same height of six foot two inches
or 1.88 meters tall the next tallest
character featured in the Disney plus
series Hawkeye is Wilson Fisk or Kingpin
coming in at six foot three inches or
1.91 meters tall since Kingpin was first
featured in the Netflix series Daredevil
it'll be interesting to see how his
character is used in the MCU in the
future
our next characters are Loki and John
Walker or us agent and they share a
certain level of villainy as well as the
same height of six foot four inches or
1.91 meters tall up next we have Ronan
the Accuser and Thor odinson again these
characters are very unlike but both
still measure in at six foot six inches
or 1.98 meters tall next is Jennifer
Walters or She-Hulk with a height of
seven foot or 2.13 meters tall if you're
interested in She-Hulk you should check
out my video on her series and how to
correctly break the fourth wall also hit
the Subscribe button while you're at it
it doesn't hurt trust me the next
tallest characters are Venom who made a
small cameo in the MCU and cord Thor's
Cronen Warrior friend these two share a
height of seven foot seven inches or
2.31 meters tall up next is Ultron
featured in Avengers Age of Ultron and
the Disney plus series what if measuring
in at 8 feet or 2.44 meters tall one of
our favorite gamma-powered characters
Bruce Banner or the Hulk is the next
tallest MCU character with a height of 8
foot 2 inches or 2.49 meters tall
slightly taller than the Hulk though is
Thanos the Mad Titan on a quest to
collect all six Infinity Stones he
measures in at just one inch taller than
the Hulk eight foot three inches or 2.51
meters tall up next is the Destroyer
featured in the film Thor and this
monstrous character has a height of 9
feet or 2.74 meters tall
the next largest MCU character is Emile
Blonsky or Abomination the former
special ops British Marine with gamma
irradiated blood and he measures in at
11 feet or 3.35 meters tall even taller
than Abomination is the fully grown
Groot with a height of 12 foot 4 inches
or 3.76 meters tall again he too can
change his height as needed but
typically Falls in at this level up next
is uwatu the Watcher featured in the
series what if although his size varies
from time to time his normal height is
20 feet or 6.1 meters tall the next
largest character is gargantos the
one-eyed 54 foot or 16.5 meter tall
monster featured in doctor strange and
the Multiverse of Madness
back up on the list next is Ant-Man or
giant man with a Max height of 109 feet
or 33.2 meters tall
although he bragged about reaching 65
feet tall in Ant-Man and the WASP he far
surpassed that in the final battle in
Avengers end game for reference 100 feet
tall would be approximately the size of
three school buses up next is a chatari
leviathan one of the flying monsters
seen in several Avengers movies with a
height of 200 feet or 61 meters tall
this is one monster I wouldn't want to
cross
the next largest monster in the MCU is
the great protector featured in Shang
Chi and the legend of the ten Rings this
Tallow based dragon has a height of 240
feet or 73 meters tall up next is Amit
the crocodile goddess featured in the
Disney plus series Moon Knight with a
height of 550 feet or 168 meters tall
that's over the height of one and a half
football fields put together slightly
taller than omit though is konshu the
moon God who fought Amit in the finale
of Moon Knight his height comes in at
560 feet or 171 meters tall now we're
about to get into the really big
characters up next is surter the fire
giant responsible for the destruction of
Asgard in the event known as Ragnarok
after putting his crown into the Eternal
Flame his height reached over a thousand
feet or 305 meters tall even larger than
surter though is dormammu the ruler of
the dark dimension featured in the film
Doctor Strange his height comes in at
1200 feet or 366 meters tall
next up is the celestial s on the
Searcher who once wielded the Power
Stone as shown in the first Guardians of
the Galaxy film
he measures in at over 2 000 feet or 610
meters tall now for the second largest
character in the MCU we have airsham the
judge with a height of over 10 million
feet or 3.05 million meters tall with a
size easily able to be seen in outer
space from planet Earth this is one of
the largest characters we've ever seen
on screen in the MCU but there's still
one character larger than erishem last
but not least we have ego The Living
Planet as the largest character in the
MCU father to Peter Quill or Star-Lord
ego was featured in the film Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 2 and he's the size of
an entire planet with a diameter of 21
million feet or 6.4 million meters
across there's just about no competition
for ego in this entire video while some
of these sizes are just estimates
comparing what we've seen in TV shows
and movies it's still crazy to see just
how much of a size difference there can
be all in one Cinematic Universe with
some characters smaller than an atom and
others as large as a an entire planet
also I can't wait to know if we'll get
to see Galactus in the MCU as he's the
biggest character yet in Marvel Comics
able to swallow entire planets whole but
please drop your thoughts in the comment
section below also check out the video
on your screen for some more of my
content don't forget to like And
subscribe and thanks for watching Rocket
Riley
[Music]